[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is a segment where viewers try to
find mistakes on our show real viewers
try to find real mistakes
we're the only show that dares our
viewers to find an error okay that has
the courage to do it so far hundreds of
challengers over the last several years
not one winner
not one no one's found a mistake well
tonight a fan named Braxton Anderson
thinks he caught a mistake he says it
happened during one of our shows at
Comic Con last week hey Conan last
week's episode yet a segment where you
dressed a killer whale as Yoda from Star
Wars pretty cool costume for comic-con
who are you who you supposed to be yet
you gave them a red lightsaber
everyone knows Yoda carries a green
lightsaber this is why I recommend you
go home isolate yourself from friends
and family and we watch the trilogy's
and may the force be with you
I didn't hear one word that guy said I
was distracted by his signed photo of
Terry Bradshaw
[Applause]
he likes Star Wars and Terry Bradshaw
those two rarely come together well I'm
very sorry
Braxton but you are wrong now I could
tell you why you're wrong but maybe it's
better if you hear it from the Yoda
killer whale himself let's bring him out
here
[Applause]
very nice very nice saya thank you stage
hands he doesn't move as well outside
the ocean say hello there killer whale
okay now tell us if you're supposed to
be Yoda why isn't your lightsaber green
it has blood on it what are you talking
about
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we're together
killer whale I gotta say it looks like
you did what you had to do do you have
anything now to say to Braxton
[Applause]
true story I gave the special effects
guy a hard time did I nodded and
universal for not using enough water
clearly dousing me was some kind of
prank revenge so anyway the challenge
still stands
you think you spotted an error on our
reporter team koco.com / haha I find an
error we'll sort it out right here on
the air let's see if you have what it
takes to make chalk meat out of the mice
trip we'll take a break wasn't that a
great clip subscribe to my youtube
channel for an endless supply of me
[Laughter]